is it a he is it a she what is the dude
we all know all we know is that traders
who are also trying to crack this
mystery call him the dude he first
appeared on the scene about a year and a
half ago traders say when when they
noticed a 450 million dollar trade being
placed that's almost double the daily
average of for the borsa Istanbul and
they've been trying to crack this
mystery for a year and a half and yet so
that's he's what we what we suspect is
what trader suspect is that this is
probably an algorithm or a
high-frequency trading firm that's
skipping from one broker to the other
and that's yeah that's that's a story
and is the dude scaring away competitors
definitely definitely I mean the traders
that we've talked to and who are trying
to who are who are trading this market
or are nervous that any any any
positions that they will place the this
so-called the dude will come and trade
trading against them I mean there's been
a there's been a spike in volatility on
days where he or she is is active so
that's that's been the main market
impact here constituent it sounds like
this is attracting a lot of interest
from traders it's become a bit of a
parlor game to try to find out the
dude's identity is it attracting
regulatory interest what regulators
looking at here so far there's been no
no comment from from the regulator to
the story what we do know is that the
Board says Istanbul has invested heavily
in and it's high-frequency
infrastructure so if this is in fact a
high frequency or algo trader then the
borsa may Pro may welcome him because
this is this is what they're this is the
kind of trading that they're they're
aiming to attract mark mentioned that 8%
uptick in volume not out of character
when you look at emerging markets right
you see spikes like that from time to
time in other emerging markets that's
that's true I mean it's also not unusual
for a single for a single buyer to move
emerging markets like this what's
strange is what's particular about this
case is the the size of the trades that
this suspected of the the suspected fund
has been putting on I mean one local
brokerage here and
particular I mean in first two months of
the year and that at one point two
million long trades that's double the
second competitor so I mean there's
there's definitely there's definitely
something something up in trader traders
are trying to crack it as well